avast ye yellow landlubber he fancy  yourself a proper pirate aye or at  volcano island the terrible ghost pirate  known as captain dread leg be hauled up  if he can defeat his Banda salty  scallywags  well his gold be all yours  Jessie every pirate needs a treasure  what's that not enough gold for yer is  it  spoken like a true pirate let me mark  your maps my Treasure Island but beware  those be treacherous waters full of sea  monsters he must best the most terrible  one of them all  crikey the cracker  keelhaul that slippery skirt and his  pileup under will be yours that are  taking pirates don't need an invitation  we take walkie right that's what we do  we're pirates